yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby Tom
McDonald been a fan for a while glad
you're here thanks brother yeah I tried
getting on a while jelly roll connected
us jelly roll is your boy right yeah
jelly roll connected us he like this the
guy man he has the same Hustle Man he's
doing the damn thing he's fighting the
good fight I looked in you I'm like man
is he fighting that boy well it's
fighting with with art and smart it's
like that there's that great saying by
Einstein criticized by creating it's
kind of what you do it's what I've been
doing yeah I don't know if jelly would
would be able to say that give me the
same glowing review these days now that
he's sort of at the Grammys yeah yeah
yeah he's such a good guy though he's
amazing he's amazing yeah yeah I don't
know how it is I you know he's who would
have thought like he's just like he's
hosting American Idol like American Idol
like jelly Ro has tattoos on his face
he's like an American Idol he's at the
gramy hope for guys like me man yes yeah
yeah it's a matter of time bro you got
Ben Shapiro you got other people in the
mix it's exciting I don't know if you go
from rap song with Ben Shapiro to
hosting American Idol but like you never
never know these days they need ratings
that's that's true that's true true and
the fact that you made that work like I
was like a Ben Shapiro and it was it was
really got really well done yeah it just
it was musically kind of like it worked
well I mean Ben did his thing man like
it was actually I was horrified like
when when we first met with Ben's team
and and we did a little interview on the
Shapiro show and Ben kind of made a joke
about like oh like maybe we can do a rap
song together sometime and we both just
kind of laughed at it and then the
second the interview ended I walked into
the living room and Nova's sitting on
the couch and I was like we got to get
bent on a rap song Like so it was your
idea yeah well we should mention that
Nova Rockefeller is your was your best
friend and now your girl yeah and has
been for a long time and she is 100%
Illuminati confirmed confirmed 100%
Illuminati yeah as of today yeah
confirmed 100% yeah yeah she's uh you
can see that and and uh there are people
right now you guys came here and for any
of you conspiracy theories and you know
I don't believe in conspiracies but
there are a lot of black vans SUVs and
black helicopters including the windows
blacked out so I don't know what the
[__] is going on but I like it so so Tom
you're totally independent and with your
success have have any of the Big Wigs
come sniffing around cuz usually they
don't care they just want numbers yeah
tons tons of times like we've we've gone
for meetings at um where was it no
something
sonyy uh yeah but tons of times like
they they I did a whole video on my on
my Instagram one time of replying to
label emails so there's one there from
uni Universal and one there from Warner
and uh I was hitting them back with
these like hilarious responses like
quoting Pink Floyd and we don't want
your your record deal and like and
sending and sending replies to them so
they they've come sniffing around like a
bunch of times but why don't you why
don't you ever want to do that well I
think it's like it's multiple things
like one like I've spent my entire
career like doing what I want when I
want saying what I want how I want to do
it uh so I'm like not interested in
being you know controlled in any way
shape or form by one of these
labels um and it's just like
I'm not interested in having my message
changed um I'm not here to do like
overproduced wrapped in plastic Mass
manufactured [__] like that's not
for me when did you when was the moment
that you decided you were going to start
talking the way you do rapping the way
you do like what was was there a moment
where you looked at the world and went I
got to do something here yeah it was
like kind of like a it was kind of a
[__] up situation honestly like it's
like kind of embarrassing but like I
used to make the same type of music that
I sort of I'm critical of now in hip-hop
like I used to make tons of Records
about cars and clothes and drinking and
partying and drugs and girls and all
that [__] like I was you know I was
emulating what my favorite rappers were
doing in my music which I think a lot of
people do that when they first start out
so I did that for a while but the
problem was like I wasn't just like
emulating it create creatively I started
like living like that and I was like
drinking all the time and partying all
the time and valuing the wrong [__]
which led to like a pretty acute stint
with like alcoholism like I was an
alcoholic for like a long time like and
it was like gnarly like those bars were
fire yeah they were yeah it was hard
Bars were Fire by the way I'm so old I
was like bars yeah was that like a
double anandra that you did yeah that
fire um so so you know I started like
emulating that lifestyle which led down
to like just a wicked stint with with
alcoholism and um that
accumulated into like a massive mental
break like I I got home from the club
one night at like 3:00 a.m. and I was
laying in bed and I had like Jimmy
Fallon or some [__] on my laptop to just
fall asleep and all of a sudden like I
had this
weird Rush of something I'm not sure
what it was and I and I got to get out
of bed and it wasn't like the drunk
wobbles it was like I turned my head in
the whole room went like and my heart
starts pounding in my chest and I'm like
oh my God I'm going to [__] die I'm
having a [__] heart attack like what
the [__] is going on and I spent from
3:00 in the morning till 9:00 a.m. the
next day like walking from my bedroom to
my bathroom and I look in the mirror I
was so white I didn't even recognize
myself and I walked back to my bedroom
and it was dark and I turned the lights
on and then by the time I got back to
the bathroom back to my bedroom the
lights were bothering me and I turned
the lights off like I was losing it I
was just losing my mind um so I had this
big mental break and I was like laying
on the floor and I called my mom and she
didn't answer and I left like a really
scary voicemail on her phone like I need
I need help like something's you know
going Uh something's going south so like
my ma ended up like I went to all these
doctors and they put me on all these
pills like um they put me on Adavan they
put me on Sak Quil they put me on like
all this different types of [__] uh
superlex and nothing was helping I was
just like mentally not there I couldn't
talk on the phone I couldn't go outside
I couldn't exercise I was like I
couldn't eat like I'd wake up in the
morning I'd fry one egg and I'd eat one
egg a day and I'd be like gagging trying
to get one egg down I was so sick so
this this this whole thing this was a
mental thing going on yeah it was like
some sort of like acute anxiety
depression like just totally dissociated
from the world around me like it was
gnarly so this went on for like 10
months I had to I had to my M got like a
friend of mine to break into my house
kidnap me take me to the airport put me
on a plane and send me home how old were
you this is like six years ago so
like
20 28 or 29 wow so yeah so I went back
home and uh lived with my ma for like 10
months and it was like it was tough dude
like I said two things to her every day
I'd wake up in the morning she'd say how
you doing I'd say not good she' go to
work work she'd come home from work she
say how you doing I'd say not good and
I'd go to bed and when I was laying in
bed at night man I'd have like a podcast
playing on my phone a show on my laptop
because if I didn't if I wasn't totally
surrounded by something like the silence
I would have killed myself Jesus it it
was horrible you felt you felt that you
felt truly suicidal yeah every minute of
every day like and then I I ended up
going to the doctor and I was like Hey
like I haven't said this in in such
basic terms to a doctor yet but like if
you don't give me something right now to
like take the edge off I'm goingon to
kill myself I'm not going to be here
tomorrow like I'm going to kill myself
today if you don't give me something so
he gave me some like kickass like Adavan
Xanax type [__] I went home and took it
and cuz it was it the anxiety or the
depression it was both both it was
constant all the time [__] answer is D
yeah yeah exactly right yeah so hey man
so were you like scared no because
sometimes it's you don't know depression
or anxiety it's all the same [__] well
yeah well it was it was a bunch of
different [__] that all formed this like
this inner turmoil it was like [__]
weird so I got home and I took this this
pill that he gave me and like 30 minutes
later I had chilled out and for like the
first time in like 10 months I [__]
felt like myself damn and I was like
holy [__] like I remembered like who I
was like I hadn't made music I talked to
my friends like nothing I was like lit
when you hear people say oh he's a shell
of who he used to be like I always sort
of roll my eyes at like abstract [__]
like that and this was that like I was
looking in the mirror and I was like I
look like me but I don't [__]
recognize me so I took that pill um and
I sort of I got a hold on like who I was
and I just [__] had a death grip on
it and I just took you know the pills
for a very short period of time so I
could get comfortable feeling in my own
body again cut off the pills went to
therapy uh did a lot of research and
reading about mental illness exercised
all the [__] time cut out all
caffeine all fast food no soda no
cigarettes no weed no alcohol nothing
like Stone Cold Sober um and sort of
like as I the you know the smoke started
to clear I was like I don't want to make
music anymore that's going to influence
people to go down the same path that I
did CU it was so [__] destructive to
me and I feel like that type of music
like if you listen to it that's fine I'm
critical of it but like I'm not like
don't listen to it just understand what
you're listening to it's like this is
branding and and and and corporate
initiatives and and and you know and and
and marketability and if you understand
that then I think you're immune to the a
lot of the negative effects that you can
experience from that type of [__] so um
so I just had this like you know just
come to Jesus moment where like I had an
epiphany and I was like I don't want to
make that [__] no more I want to instead
of making music that's going to erode
people sort of like uh morality like I
want to make music that's that's going
to inform people about [__] and wake
people up and Empower people and um that
was sort of the moment where I was like
[__] it I'm going to make music about
the [__] that I'm truly interested in
which is not cars and clothes and
[__] it's it's [__] it's politics
it's the truth behind you know it's
Truman Show [__] it also Makes You
Different yeah like otherwise you're
just another you know white rapper
rapping about cars and hoes and boats
you right and I I I think I think I
don't even know if if you're a
conspiracy theorist cuz when I listen to
your lyrics it's like you're talking
about almost like we're being fed
[__] which is this ideology and then
you're going but like 2 plus two is just
four it's kind of how I look at it yeah
you're literally going that you guys are
telling me 2 plus 2 is 16 and I'm
telling you that 2 plus 2 is four yeah
because it's just simple math it's like
I mean obviously the way you do it is
different but yeah it's it's like you're
the kind of conspiracy theorist I like
agree
they label you a conspirac theist uh I
mean I I kind of am to some degree like
I'm into that [__] just because it's
interesting to me but like it's it's
better than what we're being told well
that's for sure but the conspiracy like
if you look at like they were talking
about um OIC which is right now OIC is
the it's a European company it got Oprah
skinny dude it's well it's crazy though
but but it's a [__] fascinating thing
because so OIC comes along it is besides
statens the most successful drug in the
history of all drugs because people are
losing an average of 17% of their body
weight and all that stuff it's supposed
to be for a diabetes that's how Statin
is like a a cholesterol okay but OIC is
so big that the company itself I I can't
remember what it was but it's it's more
profitable at this point I think than
any other company ever has been in this
short period of time like epidemic Mak
think about it you just got to take a
shot and you but here's the thing that
they don't tell you so so OIC now is
it's considered a lifetime drug they
want you on at Lifetime and for the
first time the national Pediatric
Society is saying it's the first line of
defense against teen obesity so if
you're a teen what they're saying and
now the national Diabetes Association is
saying what they're saying as long as
you're on this medication that we're
going to sell you that's also subsidized
by the government that we make a fortune
off of that Wall Street makes a fortune
off of as long as you're on this drug
these drugs and you're on OIC you you
never have to change your diet so keep
eating all these simple sugars that big
food is telling you that that's number
one so there's nothing wrong with the
way you eat now you got Oprah who comes
on and says oh by the way it's not about
personal responsibility if you're obese
it's not your fault it's a brain problem
she just said that you want to talk
about a conflict of interest she she
makes a fortune with we so you got to
just all you need is our drugs so was
EMP how about this this is the most
incredible thing
OIC has who is their lobbyist the n
ACP the National Association of Colored
people black basically are are are their
lobbyists because they're saying to
Congress if you so so you can use your
food stamps in this country for soda for
soda for diabetes water you can use your
food stamps not in Europe this is what
you can use your food stamps for they
said this is not a lot of politicians
were like you're [__] paying people
you're paying you're subsidizing soda
companies to get people fat don't where
we got the medicine for it if now the
NAACP with the help of OIC saying if you
Lobby against OIC which is if you say
change your you're racist it's racist
change your diet don't change your diet
don't eat simple foods keep eating the
[__] that we're feeding you just eat
less of it and we'll give you we'll keep
you on this drug for life and what
they're fing with those EMP is it causes
stomach paralysis here's the other
[__] up thing about OIC 95% of the
seratonin that you make is for your head
is made in the gut and because it [__]
with your gut and causes different kinds
of issues in your gut because it has to
it has to stop depressed it's causing
major suicidal ideation they're skinny
yeah and as these drugs go up right yeah
but you're skinny but you're skinny so
it works better to be better to leave
sad and skinny I'd rather be sad and
skinny than S fat skinny than dead and
fat yeah that's what pi your poison be
let's take a little break dude you are
buzzing these days cuz we're doing a
live fire the kids that's right baby a
is mean February 15 not August 15th
website says 2004 also wrong February
15th one show only one freaking show
only at 10 p.m. at the Vulcan gas
theater it's the stepmother ship Brian K
and myself with a very special guest
live firing the kid it's going down one
show only one night only in Austin we're
doing a red and sea there so come get
you some but you've been buzzing dude
and I've had a concussion so we've been
using some THC gummies that's our secret
listen man cuz we partnered up with five
to give you free $40 bottle of five
Daily Buzz gummies all you got to do is
pay shipping and handling enjoy taking
them before a podcast like we two to 5
milligrams of th and that's enough for
you to feel it they're called Daily Buzz
gummies because that's enough to give
you a Daily Buzz I do it at night to
wind down dude five is fully legal ships
all 50 states third party lab tested
grown in the US OFA and you can get it
for free by visiting 5 f f i v cbd.com
fighter I like their daily sour that's
what I do at night the daily sour it's
supposed to be good if you have a
concussion I'm out of it right now it's
a $40 bottle for free you just pay
shipping and handling if you go to 5
cbd.com
fighter okay talk to me about O'Reilly I
need spark plugs I need wiper blades I
need stuff for a car well you wouldn't
need spark plugs you have an electric
terrible car but you would need wiper
blades you would need wiper blades you
could do that um I'll for you I guess
it's O rewards bonus points month all
month long at O'Reilly Auto Parts shop
in store or online to receive points get
reward sent straight to your phone or
inbox get two three four even five times
bonus points on select purchases receive
bonus points on select items throughout
the store like wiper blades B antifreeze
you don't need that either coolant you
don't need cuz your stupid car parts
cleaner motor oil which you don't need
for your stupid car and there's so much
more these bonus points can help you get
to your next reward even FAS you receive
$5 reward for every 150 o reward points
to use on your next in store or online
purchase members can check points and
rewards online anytime if you're an
already an old Rewards member and not
receiving your rewards just add your
email address or mobile phone number you
get 10 bucks reward for updating your
existing account if you're not an O
reward member yet o Rewards member yet
sign up is quick easy online at oilly
auto.com or in store at oilly Auto
Hearts I use them all the time wow all
the time oh o O'Reilly
oy so so that to me as far as like a
conspiracy just follow the money it we
are this is madness yeah like that that
same energy with Co y facts I mean fact
hey booster boy over here I didn't get a
booster [__] booster boy oh you got the
first one no yeah you did okay no I did
not what is this like a point of
contention no no I no we both we did not
but uh we did in other words go
somewhere and no I I never got
vaccinated cool cool good yeah well
you're still here the first time I said
that we not say that I don't think you
are why can't he say it cuz I said who's
going to get him in trouble Showtime I
don't know dude no airport Oh no you're
looking at HR I don't think the airports
aren't doing that anymore I'm HR no
Airport's not doing it if you go to a
different country don't they still check
sometimes you have to have a card no no
you don't Canada doesn't check they all
stop the co epidemic you did have to
have those days are over but even even
the medical centers in La dro the mass
lot of things you had to have but in
like retro when they like something okay
I just marked it I marked it in the
podcast you see that he's compromised no
it's not that listen I care about you
guys how do I get in trouble no listen I
got I have look I got of the yeah dude
this episode's brought to you by big
farma you [__] I I have my official
vaccin I'm telling you he drives a Tesla
too yeah oh that was you out in the lot
that's I have to go on that rant about
my my uh I don't I don't know what
you're worried about they still got you
shook well no it's just that I certain
places you're not allowed I went through
yeah or you get it and then you're
compromised you got heart issues no I'm
I didn't get it I that's what I'm saying
like what are they going to do this is
wild I wasn't the reason I didn't get
the VAC the the covid vaccine is I was
going to Europe and I didn't have time
CU you have to space it out so you have
to get the first one that the second one
right and I but I was going to Europe
and of course I I I procrastinate so I I
was going I get the if I got the first
one I have to wait like three weeks to
get the second one but I was already
going to be in Europe so I was like I
can't do that I got to figure something
else out well timing is everything yeah
now did you get did you get vaccinated
[__] no
yeah what no [__] no [__] no I love it
yeah I'd rather [__] go lay in the
street which is probably safer yeah so
yeah well now kids get I think what 70
vaccines when they used to get when I
was growing up I got
six so it's all it's all [__] unbel
it's all dicey so yeah I don't even I
don't even you know it's not even
conspiracy theories at this point it's
just [__] a lot of the conspiracy
theory [__] that they're labeling now is
like oh that's a conspiracy theory just
like to me and to a lot of other people
just seems like common sense [__] and
then but they th they throw the word
conspiracy on any like if you bring up
anything agenda he's a conspiracy the so
conspiracy theorist now is like a
negative term when the government
started with JFK like you look how much
they' used the word conspiracy theorist
when it started with JFK at first it was
like one or two times then the JFK stuff
hit and then the newspapers ran with it
used like 10,000 conspiracies have
always been a thing but like you can't
say that whatever happened to you with
this Megan the stallion thing in you
that you were talking about on your on
your on Instagram you cannot tell me
that that's not in some way ways that
sounds conspiratorial it sounds like
certain people in power in the music
business were like we can't have this
independent artist with his conservative
quote unquote message beating out Megan
stallion but you know why right because
they're not part of it so they don't get
a chunk of it so what they want to do is
no no suppress that cuz they don't want
more of TOMS they want less they can't
control they're on the losing side
exactly yeah 100% and it's just like
[__] man it's not even
if if I was coming straight out the blue
and saying like hey this and this and
this is happening with with with the
Billboard charts in regards to this song
with Ben and that was the first time
anything that had happened
like I could understand people being
like Ah that's just a conspiracy or at
least being skeptical of it but this is
like not the first time we've been
[__] with like in
2021 I released an album that I it did
[__] 60,000 digital sales the album
and I sold 50,000 physical copies damn
which would have made it the number one
album on Billboard period by a [__]
long shot would have smoked everyone and
billboard said at Billboard's request I
put [__] barcodes and [__] on my
albums which is something I've never
[__] done before cuz Bill wanted the
the they bar codes be so they're like
make sure you put barcode so we can
track it does that so they can track the
same so they can actually track the
sales sales yeah so I was like okay fine
we'll put we'll put barcod barcodes on
the album like no [__] problem so we
we pressed the 50,000 copies or whatever
put barcodes on the [__] things
supplied them with the information from
the barcodes and they're
saying we need more than that and I'm
like okay well what do you need and
they're like we need to see sales
reports so I'm like Okay so we've
screenshot all the sales reports from
the back end of my store like my
e-commerce [__] give them all the
screenshots from the sales reports
they're like that's not enough and I was
like okay we'll check it out I'll create
you a [__] profile on my website
right now yeah go on yourself I'll give
you a password you can sign in to my
e-commerce store and and which is
[__] dangerous for me wow I can't
believe yeah W but you're trying to make
a point yeah I'm trying to show like not
just for my personal like rah rah we
beat the [__] music industry but I
have a lot of friends that are
independent musicians and I want them to
know like hey you can be [__]
successful outside of the music industry
you can create your own ecosystem
outside of this machine and you can beat
them at their own [__] game right
it's [__] possible so I'm doing it
it's a personal thing but it's it's more
than that it's for everybody else so I
say okay here I've made you a a a a
login I I've given you a password and
they refused and this is like no [__]
[__] this is three and a half weeks
on the phone with these people
communicating via email every single
[__] day for hours I'm talking to
people at billboard I'm talking to
people at MRC data who collects the
sales numbers for billboard and MRC
saying No this is a billboard issue and
billboard saying no it's an MRC issue
there's no [__]
accountability um and it just it ended
up happening like if if we don't get
these guys the the access or the the the
proof that they require within x amount
of time then we're [__] when we're
just going with with with what our
whatever our digital numbers are and I
and that's unprecedented access here's a
[__] username and a password you can
sign in you can verify the sales in real
time on your own with no oversight from
anybody you're free to do what you want
they just [__] said no pretty much
told us to go [__] ourselves yeah I'm
curious if there's another like a kid
who who wants to Aspire to be who's
listening it's like God it sounds like a
nightmare like you can see why they sign
with big but you corporations yeah but
you know what I think you're on The
Winning Side of History I think that
didn't dependent artist are I mean
you're doing it you're actually doing it
are you get aren't you getting a lot of
people that reach out to you say like
with support oh [__] yeah yeah yeah
that's why like I I just look at it this
is just revenge of the independent
artist at this point they don't have
anything that I need I bought half a
million dollars worth of cameras I
bought half a million dollars worth of
lenses I have half a million dollars
worth of Lights I have [__] YouTube
and Facebook and Instagram and Rumble
and all the all the other Twitter I
don't know what they could offer you
love it yeah I don't know how was that
video doing on Rumble I have no idea
yeah I have no idea but I had 5 million
views on on Twitter it's got [__] 14
million views on YouTube get 90,000
single sales on iTunes alone like it's
it's [__] crushing so there's just
like there's no resources that they can
offer us the only thing that they have
that we don't have is relationships and
they use those relationships to [__]
[__] block us and put up barriers in
places and prevent us from getting into
rooms that's why it's so [__] awesome
to to have guys like here always here
for you that that will give people a
platform because you know there's a lot
of other big platforms out there that
whether people want to believe it or not
are are controlled and there's
Gatekeepers and they the whole thing is
in such a bummer because podcasts were
the answer with were sort of that that
was the whole point of podcast have you
done Rogan no huh yeah I mean yeah we
we've always been this way I mean we got
fired from Fox cuz they were trying to
control stuff and he's like don't talk
about this on the podcast I'm like can't
do that yeah like d I'm you talk about
it you can get fired I'm like all right
dude well it's what we do I went in the
next day we talked about it and came
back the following day and they had
security let me he went bad on Fox when
we're in the fox
room they want 50% of our [__] I'm like
noten there some giant football player
that I guess you know I don't know you
were like I mean if the guy wants to if
they want to if he he's a giant guy I
mean if he wants to I mean cause a
problem I'm here they won't let us get
back in the studio and get our stuff
wild yeah wild wild yeah that was
actually that's right we had to just I
was like what do you mean we can't get
back in there I if I could just get the
sign like no absolutely yeah but I I
yeah I think it works out you know I
think it works out I don't I don't
sometimes I don't think you do things
because they work out I think you do
things because the right thing to do the
right thing to do I think that if you
don't if you don't stand for something
you stand for [__] nothing and if
you're not willing to fight for
something that you can Define then
you're not a fully formed human being
that's what I respect so much about you
is because you're you're you're
criticizing by creating and you're
putting your money where your mouth is
and it's working out I mean the plus
also is that you're super talented I
mean I'm not a rap officient Auto well
that you have to talented you're not sit
on this couch but you're not some if
you're not talented there's no argument
CU then the corporates just like look at
him he sucks but they can't use that you
know so I think that's kind tal number
one otherwise there's no there's no
fight yeah I think that's kind of what
they tried to do with like the Ben
record right is like because there like
I'm not I'm not daed to the fact that
there's like the novelty is [__]
thick with with the Ben thing and it is
like a big [__] troll like it's
[__] Ben Shapiro like does he have
does he have any business being on a
[__] rap song [__] no that's why
humor yeah yeah but but the but the
Press you know they're like oh this
talentless hack Tom McDonald has put
this this other [__] idiot Ben
Shapiro on I love this dude it's love it
yeah that the The Narrative and like
look he has to use bench paare to get
views it's like oh you guys have no clue
what you're talking about he said videos
way bigger than this yeah TMZ B videos
are bigger than you yeah and so like TMZ
dragged us [__] Forbes like Loki kind
of dragged us like pretty much 90% of
the press coverage but think about the
Press is Bubba you know what I'm saying
they're all over here all over here of
course so so they they all [__]
dragged us and made it seem like I'm
some talentless clickbait gimmicky guy
and this is my big moment in the sun
with Ben and it's like yo like I've sold
[__] probably a million hard copies
of my CDs over the last six but those
people that read then go oh yeah it's a
gimmick you don't even want you don't
want them to the she that read you don't
want that yeah did you see LA Times how
many people they had to lay off how many
journalists nobody's reading the Ali
times nobody's reading these [__] cuz
they don't trust them cuz they've lost
trust but you would think like those big
corporations whether it's CNN even Fox
but like all the like LA Times New York
Post rolling ston You' be ESPN like
everything's headed down nothing's on a
positive scale so you think they go okay
what we're doing is not working Joe
Rogan just himself has had a huge effect
on on boys from the age of 12 to like 22
my son who's 12
is
basically a conservative because he's
listening he and his friends are all
listening to Rogan listening to guys
like you they it just because they've
been they've been kind of demonized
they've been told that they are the
problem and so kids are like but then
they get a guy like you and they're
listening like but that's how I feel I'm
not a bad person I just I'm competitive
I want to do Sports I I want to [__]
around and be funny I I don't want to
feel like a librarian's always watching
me I don't want to feel like there's a
shop in the corner hey stop dancing or
rough housing boys don't rough house
that's what they're telling boys rough
house it's all we [__] do yeah you
know all we do is tease each other all
we do is say [__] we're not supposed to
say that's the whole point that is the
point that's the whole point if you tell
me I can't say it he and I before the
cameras are on the [__] that he can't
help himself he we were going live I say
every word possible we were going live
and I was like hey hey even me I was
like hey you got to calm down I was
already getting text on the way say
every word that would get can I mean we
would have gotten canceled my children
would have been canceled just for
knowing him and it Generations I got to
get it out of my you know don't tell me
not to do something it's going to
[__] cause a problem so but for for
you like uh as far as moving forward
like obious you're doing the good fight
what's the like how do you how do you
win in the end I guess just keep doing
what you're doing I mean I think at the
end of the day like when when my careers
come to a close and and I decide to walk
away from it all I think I get to pack
up with my with my Integrity still
intact and like like at the end of the
day like [__] like the billboard charts
and and and [__] like that
like I look at it as it's like a form of
like revenge for me it's like I've
entered an arena where I'm not supposed
to be and and I'm and I'm winning and I
I have like 35 or 36 or 40 some [__]
obscene number of number ones on
Billboard so like I like so when it
comes to billboard and that stuff like
once you see how the sausage is made
aren't you like I'm good I don't need it
man yeah but it's still fun yeah it's
still fun and like it's fun to stick it
to people it's like yeah like I feel
like the music industry has treated
artists like [__] for so long and like
exploited dreamers and taking advantage
of people who have a passion for this
[__] and robbed them and just God I wish
you were a UFC fighter we could use the
same energy yeah right so I feel like
they've just [__] with artists for so
long that like as long as I'm capable of
it I'm just going to [__] with them
right back and I get to walk away at the
end of the day and be like well I did it
and like whether they want to give me a
Grammy one day or not like I still made
[__] $50 million and and and had a
blast and spoke for a bunch of people
who felt like they didn't have a [__]
voice I got to speak up for people and
and be that guy on the front line and
like and that [__] helps me sleep at
night so that like that I I think that
you know you're you're so needed I think
I said this to you on the phone like
people the the I don't like saying the
right because you know everybody gets
branded far right or how about just
people who are about traditional
partially Traditional Values people say
are you right-wing I'm like I don't know
what's the subject I change all the time
I don't know but I'm I'm I'm not I'm not
you know don't try to label me the I'm
not right right I'm not going to right
well that's different that's different I
was vibing right but I but but you know
what I'm saying like you're you're
preaching to me common sense and kind of
the values that kind of built a lot of
the stuff that we enjoy all the time and
that that's what it is dude is like but
but but it's like we talked about the
conspiracy Theory label and that gets
tossed on anybody that's that's that's
interested in a narrative that's
contrary or running not parallel with
what what the mainstream narrative is to
doing the same [__] with the with the
far right rightwing thing like I've
never labeled myself as a conservative
rapper I've never labeled myself as a
rightwing white right-wing rapper I just
like the woke [__] that's going on on
the left like like the further you lean
away from that you you can lean away
from the woke [__] and and not be
leaning that's how I am exactly that's
what I do like yeah so that's kind of
they all suck like left and right suck
dude the whole I'm sure [__] not left I
know that but I'm not all the way on the
right I don't know how to be left when I
can't follow any of their rules cuz
they're always changing they're also
crazy well it's also crazy like my my
sister made a t-shirt for us the other
day that said I'm not always right but
I'm never left yeah and like that's kind
of like how I feel about [__] but but
like you know in general like the whole
the whole think most of us are that way
though and and isn't isn't the
conspiracy that they that the the people
who might not even exist are being
Amplified like think I think there's a
there's an argument being fostered by
other AG but I think that's why Trump's
getting so big because people are like
all right I'm not pro Trump but I'm sure
as [__] not this and if the options this
or this I'm going over here you see see
and that's the [__] problem is is
there like you know no no matter who you
vote for what or what team you decide to
like endorse
it's going to go to [__] anyway correct
and then they're going to be like well
you [__] you you chose this person
and it's going to [__] and it's like
okay well is it is it a democracy or is
it a [__] trick because if you give
me three sandwiches and it's [__] dog
[__] cat [__] and bird [__] and I choose
one of them and start eating it and go
wow this tastes like [__] and you say
well you chose to eat that one and I'm
like the three [__] choices you gave
all [__] exactly like that and that's
just you know from a million feet that's
what this whole thing seems like to me
it's like it's not even about like
people say like oh it's divide and
conquer and [__] it's beyond that at
this point they amplify the voices that
you're talking about so we divide
ourselves like they don't even have to C
step in and be like okay whites over
here and blacks over here and gays over
here and Straits over here they just
amplify these super [__] extreme
voices cuz they want conflict they want
conflict so we're not focused on the
real
issue nothing gets doneck dude yeah
they're busy fighting over here about
trans rights and when most are like we
don't care whatever they want to do like
no no but you hate them and it's like no
but we want to get this done yeah my my
thing is how do we deal I I think you're
exactly right I think we're being told
to look over here and there's a whole
bunch of like emotional issues kids and
trans and all we just go over here and
you got to wear masks and we're looking
over there but I think the larger threat
is as technology becomes what it is and
as we are able to be more and more
independent you can see that you don't
really need a record label you could
make the argument that the political
system as it is the president as a
figurehead is no longer the is no longer
um as relevant you need laws and you
need things like that but you could make
the argument that um what you worry
about is technology is making it very
easy to control people on a massive
level dude I am up to my neck in
insurance right now I had a little issue
with the TRX by a little issue means I
rolled it so I'm dealing with insurance
I wish it was easier wish there was
something Progressive okay all right
it's the enter your name enter enter
enter the Name Your Price tool from
Progressive okay you mean I can call my
shots look the name your put you in
charge of your auto insurance by working
just the way it sounds okay you tell
Progressive how much you want to pay for
car insurance then they'll show you a
variety of coverages that fit within
your budget giving you options okay it's
freaking easy to start a quote you'll be
able to choose the best option for you
it's fast it's just one of the many ways
you can save with Progressive Insurance
get a quote today at progressive.com to
try the Name Your Price tool for
yourself and join the over 28 million
drivers who TR Progressive that's a lot
of drivers they can't all be wrong 28
million Progressive casual insurance
company and Affiliates price and
coverage match limited by state law
Progressive listen dude I'm wearing true
classic underwear right now because
that's the only thing you'll see if I if
you strip me down and we got to go at it
if we got to get to wrestling if I got
to get low on you and these jeans are
restricted I might be distracted yeah
well you're going to be distracted by my
Apple bottom cuz nothing nothing hugs my
three pie set my that sweater they giv I
would wear it every day if I could
today's rainy I wish I was in that true
classic sweer in I have it in my car
jeans are nice you can wear it with a
it's it's so soft on your skin you don't
need like a long sleeve shirt you know
when you I you we the long sleeve on her
sweatshirt anyways right that's stupid
with a sweater itchy not the true class
bad though hugs your body feels real
good all the merch boy merch F kid merch
it's all true classic we've been using
them forever for ever look look look if
you want to work out get the stank free
moisture ricking shirts they got this
technology it's unbelievable I'll tell
you what go to some company that charges
a fortune for all their workout clothes
then get your true classic and take a
look at the Quality how about for
Valentine's Day you got a date coming up
you want to be a little hot TI it you
got to dress nice dude let true classic
help you out PE a little fit for your
day get him some active wear shirts
shorts go for you know whatever it is
they got joggers they got they gotos if
you want to look good they're just rock
their plain te's and hoodies it's my
absolute favorite anytime you see a
t-shirt I'm rocking it's always true me
too I think if I'm on stage it's 100% a
true classic so if you're ready to
upgrade your closet shop now with
exclusive Link at true classic.com
fighter you get 25% off your first order
no matter how you move make 2024 your
most comfortable year yet with true
classic once again that's true
classic.com fighter and save it 25% off
your first order ooh 25% by the way the
reason you wear them the reason I wear
them is they hug my chest and arms and
they're Lo in the front and that makes
me feel and look a little more muscular
which is important to me true classic so
just take just take but that's not
always good it's not AI is the real
danger and dude even [__] as stupid as
like the self-driving cars it's like
people are like oh it's so convenient
and it's like yeah well wait till you
get in that [__] one day and it
takes you to the courthouse for
something you didn't you didn't even
know you did correct or they decide you
didn't pay parking ticket and you can't
drive to get to the hospital ex exactly
or you can't take your [__] money out
of your account with the with the or or
your money or your money expires or they
have an exporation but it's also another
way to control you like electric cars is
not the vibe for million [__] reasons
and it's another way you you don't want
to drive anymore you don't have any
control they want to set the speed limit
you just want to get in and not drive
you be a bigger [__] you can't drive to
work I drive a Tesla and he can't call
me a harder cuck he's like you he he
goes you're not allowed in my truck
though because you're a [__] and my
truck won't start my truck won't start
cuz you're a cop and you're probably
vaxed to the max can't get CU it's it's
that culture that subscribes to like I
electrics whatever but the culture
surrounding it it's the same culture
that wants to get VX that the alpha
males are the enemy let's not get
carared away electric cars are pretty
awesome they're not though in any facet
what do you mean how are they awesome
they're fast as [__] I I don't car's not
fast my car's not fast your car's not
fast by all measurements your car is not
fast my car jumps off the line they
don't though there's there's gas power
cars that do if your arguments that it's
fast then you would drive a fast car
before this I mean I don't care yeah
that's what I'm saying you don't care
you're doing it cuz it's easy but people
don't realize like we're on our cell
phone so we're living living in
simulation so you're always on your cell
phone so you're living in that world you
get in your car you PL plug in the
address it drives you there it's just
making American softer and softer just
it's convenient but you pay a price for
it like it's just it's there is
something convenient yeah like well no
yeah the price you pay is for and and
it's like everything they look exactly
the same it's white or black then tears
basic as [__] there's a screen on there
I charge it it's I let guys I let a
bunch of guys have sex with my wife I'm
you know I'm is that what you're saying
yes is that [__] life and then who owns
all the don't get me started then who
owns all the charging stations China so
we're more reliant on China here's you
[__] idiots here's what figure it out
here's what I worry about take it easy
bro figure it out get your put your hand
down dude people like they're fast I'm
like bro you drove a [__] Prius
before this have you ever Prius on
purpose they he and Rogan will be like
just buy a better car dude I was like
it's La it's parking though right that
was that the excuse I'm just not a I I
don't care I'm not a car guy but what I
think is interesting is that there's a
social credit score already happening so
I travel a lot yeah I go Airbnb I use
Uber I go I use turo which is like the
Airbnb for cars right it's all awesome
it's so convenient it it's makes
everything perfect but you get reviewed
every time you use it and they and then
you review them so now pretty soon
there's a there's a I'm attached to a do
I have five stars SC four and a half
probably five but but but I'm but I'm
aware of it but you can't a bad review
we've had horrible airbnbs I tell my
brother I'm like dude we rent this
expensive Airbnb in Kentucky you got my
dude my [__] room was behind a train
station I remember I st and I'm like I
tell my brother I'm like dude you got to
leave a battery review he's like we
can't CU if we leave a bad review then
they give us a bad review then we can't
rent the next place like so we can't say
anything he's like absolutely not you
tell them it's the best thing of all
time like this is insane although I from
what I understand they can't see your
review you can't see their they see it
yeah isn't that crazy though so now we
already have a social credit score in ex
sense we're falling into this trap of
convenience and abundance and it's
awesome but we're paying a price well I
always say it's like we used to have
privacy you're too young to remember uh
you might be most I grew up with privacy
and then when the planes hit the
buildings we said to the government you
give us our safety we'll give you our
privacy and they said we'll do that
we'll give you cameras and a mic that we
can turn on and you're going to carry it
around your in your hand that's what the
[__] is really going and then the
safety's gone now so you lost your
privacy the safety's gone cuz The
Border's open the level has been higher
do you know that they can I was talking
to a bunch of NS your phone's off they
can [__] turn your mic on I was
talking to a bunch of NSA guys they were
like get on then they're like signal on
those apps but which I think are
probably made by CIA I mean I but it's
really interesting they're only private
for now
too I feel like every the place that
we're at now with the self-driving cars
and all this [__] like on the surface
level the convenience and stuff is like
super cool but I feel like it only like
this is just like the beginning like the
the other day like the first person got
the neurol link or whatever from Elon
Musk the brain chip [__] and like I've
look look I [__] with Elon Musk I think
he's cool I think he's a very forward
thinking he has interesting perspectives
on [__] I dig it um just because it's
intriguing to me but like I've been
critical of the neurolink [__] from the
jump and people are saying like yo it's
going to cure Ms and it's going to cure
cerebral paly and it's going to cure all
this [__] and it's just like yo like
that's where it starts bro that's the
selling point corre for it now but like
where are you going to be 10 years from
now when like you have a thought and
then you go to say it and you can't get
it out your mouth like because it's
[__] govering correct what your
freedom of speech like that's where this
[__] goes or they can read your thoughts
yeah exactly that's where this [__] is
going to go down the line they're not
going to come out the box and be like
hey this is capable of [__]
controlling you from within they're
going to be like hey this is this could
save your mom's life or it could it
could make your grandfather walk again
or you know well you're also they're
also going to be able to hire digital
archists so you go to a job and they're
going to hire a digit archist he's going
to be a forensics he's going to be a
computer hacker who will find everything
you've ever written or sent every text
you sent everything you everything
you've ever done and they're going to
find that and then they can comb through
what what they consider objectionable
but if you look at it's just making
everyone softer and softer and softer
like the the new generation like that's
why my kids whenever I'm doing anything
in my cars I take them with me they need
to know how to change tires change the
oil cuz now like your son he's coming up
now dad has electric car
Okay Tire blows oil they have no clue
they somebody with rough hands of course
it's just making it's just making those
people sof I call my wife and she comes
out with her rough hands
yeah shut up Brandon I [__] my car
jumps off the line admit that the
Tesla's fast no what is it what is a
Tesla keep hearing that though I keep
hearing Tesla r on what's the Tesla hold
on let's Tesla 3 0 to 60 you're out of
your mind watch this [__] but what's
faster you be BBA that thing you're
going to be like I saw a video of the
Tesla truck towing at 911 so no 4.1 is
when they actually tested it bring up
Dodge D 170 0 to 60 where know and my
truck's faster than that bab by the way
the 7,000 power pound truck is faster
yeah but you have 1,200 horsepower
doesn't matter still faster than your
car but you had to put 12200 in oh then
my car that I got from the factory at
Dodge is 1.6 seconds you cuck no it's
not true no that's true hold on
fashion your plaid that you guys bow
down to oh that's that Dodge Demon yeah
that green car out there starches all
your gay electric stuff why is it gay oh
and then you have to charge yours why is
that gay and you got to charge it I keep
going you got to charge it yeah but I
mean what like I don't know why I'm gay
it doesn't mean I bang guys it does
though or do it means guys got bang me
either or okay wait you think that's
what is gayer though if if I bang guys
that's almost straight sure man I'm just
I don't know you Tom you you know the
I'm not yeah I'm not jumping in on that
one are you a I think I think yeah gay
goes either way like yeah are you a car
guy not really but um I'll tell you this
you're not an electric car guy I'm
definitely not electric car guy I can
tell you that then he's a car
guy hey what the [__] is going on here
man you got boosted you drive the T I
never got boosted voted for Kamala
Harris I just want to get all the facts
out Tom what you're dealing with here I
can expl CIA plant oh no this isn't even
my real hair um yeah yeah yeah I thought
jelly roll was going to win last night
for Best New Artist then I saw the
lineup like stiff
competition they have a tough time
giving it to the newbies too like and
jelly roll has been doing this [__] for
[__] 30 years or 20 years or
something like he's a vet as far as like
the game goes but in that Arena like
tough dude when I saw the lineup like
that's going to be a tough one for wi
Swift one she won album of the year like
fourth year in a row or something Jesus
she's kind of annoying I'm I don't mind
her but she always acts surprised she's
like I don't even have a speech right to
go I can't believe I'm like [__] you've
won three before this it's not like this
is unheard of she's the most famous
person in the
room she's the only artist to win that
category four times she just broke that
record yeah Nova [__] with Taylor Swift
swift over there I'm a fan I are you you
a fan I think she's awesome yeah I don't
mind her at all like the hate she gets I
don't understand it's all good not my
favorite music cuz I'm old though right
it's not for you but the I'm I'm cool
with her I like how they show in the
football games I don't mind that but
just weird how it's a weird vibe like it
feels like manufactured and she's like
oh I can't believe like it's her first
one she's like I don't have a speech
radio I didn't expect this I'm like
you're literally the most famous person
on the plan of course you're going to
win yeah I you know I I wasn't into it
at all like I was
super not into Taylor Swift and then
Nova made me listen to like a whole
bunch of her [__] and like watch a
documentary one night and I was like
[__] like stupid she's playing
instruments she's writing a lot of her
own [__] and aside from the creativity
she's like a fierce business woman beast
beast and so like respect she's still
part of like a an industry that I
[__] detest but beyond that like as
an individual mad talented yeah yeah
crazy talented I say one thing in
defense of Taylor talk the mic talk to
the mic talk the mic pull the writers
because Taylor Swift only has like two
writers on all of her songs and every
other pop song on the radio has like 9
to 11 I mean her riter did win best
producer of the year but yeah I hear you
but it's like numbers like if you look
at Tom songs it's Tom and you look at
Taylor songs Taylor Swift and the
producer and you look at any other pop
song that's on the radio and there's
like 10 people agree that's true we we
we lost a number one to uh who the [__]
Sam Smith one time and the the record
that we were up against like we were
[__] neck and neck for this number one
on Billboard so I like after we had got
edged out and I'm talking like only like
a thousand or 2,000 downloads like [__]
like I wanted to know what we were truly
competing against outside of the the
machine and the promo and all the
[__] I went looked into it and there
was like [__] 13 writers in the song
I was like damn that's that's so
impressive that you're doing that well
like I didn't realize you had that many
hits number one hits on Billboard yeah
well it's because they never write about
it is there anybody else in your lane
like anyone else doing what you
do I mean you're the original but is
there anybody else trying to do it not
not not that I know of certainly not at
the level that we're at right now we're
kind of standing here it's so cool alone
and you get paid you basically you don't
have to pay anybody you you get that
Revenue when they download yeah mhm so
great yeah that's like that's one of the
you
know aside from like not wanting to be
part of that like whole industry um
which is just like against my nature
like through and through like it's
[__] awesome that like I make all the
Beats Nova shoots all the videos D two-
Man team she's a musician in her own
right now aren't you guys like packing
up the CDs and [__] and shipping them we
were for a long time and then that's
what jelly J's like you're going to love
this dude man he's packing all his own
[__] doing all his own stuff I'm like we
recently just stopped because it got so
overwhelming which was [__] awesome
because uh my sister was a nurse in
Canada and she was a nurse through the
co [__] so there's [__] dying
in the hallways and [__] and she's
running around they didn't have PPE
she's got no mask no gloves nothing
she's in there working with sick people
all [__] day which is like you know
horrible I'm I'm like horrified from my
sister and our [__] started getting so
overwhelming at the time she called me
my sister calls me on her on her lunch
break she's in [__] tears she's so
stressed out like yo these people are
dying all around me we got no protective
gear like working [__] 90 hours a
week she's like just Gass and I was like
go in there right now and tell them that
you [__] quit leave get on a plane
and come to La you're like I have an n95
mask made out of $100 bills yeah so she
went in and [__] quit and then flew
out here and now her and her husband um
they set up the lights for Nova and I on
our music video shoots they um they run
our e-commerce they do customer service
they pack all the albums it's [__]
awesome do you do any live performance
yeah it's it's been a minute like my
last tour that's where the real that's
you're G to pack it in no okay it
depends it's like for some people yeah
that but it's a that's a little bit of
like an Antiquated system where it was
like back in the day you Dro an album
and then you toured that [__]
for like it's the real money because the
artists like Bieber and like not even
Taylor Swift they're making their money
off merge they're not making their money
off their like they're singles why
because they're with a big Corporation
takes all the [__] money yeah they
got they got a label that doesn't have
to share it with anybody they're out
their their labels taking all the money
and then going but go on T and sell the
merch you can have that where he doesn't
need to do that ex exactly wow and so
for people to download your songs they
come to your website they go they can
get them off apple and stuff well I sell
all of my physical so the way that I've
done it is like the music videos that I
shoot with Nova are my singles on my
albums um so those singles that have
Associated music videos those go to dsps
iTunes Amazon Spotify etc etc etc so
you'll get like you know most albums
these days are like 11 to 13 songs like
my albums are like 21 22 23 Songs five
of those songs become music videos which
become singles that are available
digitally and the other 19 songs are
just available on the CD so if you want
a physical album hangovergang.com
um and that's where you get my physical
albums and aside from that um you you
can get the digital versions on the
digital dsps facts matter rather be a
defensive offensive nut job than woke
without nuts and no job I'm not always
right but I'm never left facts feelings
this is [__] great this is all [__]
that like myself and Nova and my sister
like we we came up with all this stuff
for the um for the fact drop with Ben
love this [__] those are the album
that's dope yeah thanks man God so find
the good fight
man brother yeah keep it up brother
appreciate you coming on man yeah hell
yeah thanks for having me just anytime
you want like you're down the road just
anytime just call up and be like hey I
want to come on and promote something
hell yeah I've been a fan of you guys
for forever so appreciate it brother I
love hearing that when you told me I was
like that's [__] great because we we
talk about you so cool cool and we still
got to do the road we're in uh Austin on
the 15th that is did Jay fix it nope
still says 2004 February 15th that's a
Thursday
myself live firing the kid come get you
some yep and then Brian count will be uh
at the well March actually February 23rd
I'm gonna kill him uh and February 24th
at the recck room man whoever's
Louisville Comedy Club March one and two
in Bricktown comedy club in Tulsa
Oklahoma March 8 and and 7 Tom McDonald
we appreciate you brother great time
[__] he